[Laughter]
don't high-five that it's making me a
little
idiot we're never gonna hang out again
after this are we still invited to the
company Retreats here we go we're the
cast of Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania I'm Paul this is Jonathan this is
Evangeline this is Catherine and we're
going to take a quiz an MCU quiz oh here
we go we're ready we know all about yeah
foreign
first which of these Stanley cameos
happens in Ant-Man in 2015. oh I got it
the bartender the other choice is
besides a bartender we're a school bus
driver
a security guard and a judge at a beauty
pageant bartender it is the bartender
good answer yeah I had to say I got it
first because I'm not gonna do any of
the other ones it was a thrilling day I
was there and thought it was like the
president walked onto the set it was an
unreal experience it was super cool okay
in Thor what is the name of Thor's
hammer
options Odin Leslie definitely Leslie
I'm your engineering
there I think it's the sound of a sneeze
isn't it like
Jonathan
that sounds familiar I think it's the
action yeah
look I I think if all three of you want
to go with that one I think that
Jonathan sounds a little familiar to me
but maybe I'm just getting that confused
with you correct
next is in Iron Man what famous rock
song plays at the beginning when Tony is
riding with the soldiers okay this is a
little harder Master of the puppets by
Metallica Hotel California by the Eagles
Hotel California no no don't look it up
no no no I'm not okay
I want to play the song because then we
will know oh that's smart no that's not
smart that's cheating no all the same
recipes
oh nobody told me if I didn't know is it
really like cheating thank you no don't
have five of that okay next What's Next
by Jimi Hendrix but that's not it back
in Black Back in Black by ACDC I think
it's that one or the Metallica One
that's why I need to hear it I need to
hear the Master of Puppets by Metallica
to know because I know well I plan plan
you got it cute it doesn't say a song
from Iron Man it just says yeah well
with Back in Black say uh
[Music]
all right we gotta go for it all right
all right
Metallica Back in Black yeah
it's back in black guys you got it wrong
again
okay come on okay okay it's all right
can I just have a second no no
get together
I feel like Scott knew it I feel like
Paul knew it I just called him Scott
that's okay a method an Avengers end
game what food is Scott Lang trying to
eat when it's blown out of his hand oh I
know this one a burger a taco fries or
pizza don't click anything do you know
what it is I mean I can tell you guys if
you want to know no no no
Steve we're gonna go with Taco good
answer good answer
me he was right I feel like I got Taco
it's the messiest one which character
makes their MCU debut in Thor Ragnarok
Florence Pugh is it Randall Park is it
Tessa Thompson or is it Sebastian's Stan
and I believe the answer would be Jimmy
Wilson thank you correct correct all
right in Captain America Civil War what
dish does Wanda help Vision make oh
paprikash pasta and meatballs goulash or
beef stew do you know I'm not I'm not
gonna theorize if you know the answer
already
I think I am okay uh oh boy this one's a
little tougher is it I'm waffling
between goulash and paprikash paprikash
I wanna I wanna well because Wanda where
does she come from we're between goulash
and proper cash
I just want to say I'm gonna go with
goulash but I feel
popular I'm on the team
it's paprikash yeah see I was I was
gonna say paprika but nobody asked me so
this is a disaster it's a specific I'm
the new guy
I was gonna say but paprika I know I
know he's supposed to be a conqueror not
a loser that's right he's not supposed
to lose okay in Loki okay here we go all
right stand out
in Loki what does the TVA stand for
Transworld Airlines I love that time
Vortex Association the vacation Alliance
the violent academics or the time
variance Authority I want to say it's
probably the time variance Authority
what do you think you would know or is
it you're in now or is it the time
Vortex Association I would say I think
it's a Time variance it would be my
startup so yeah we're gonna go with time
variance Authority awesome yeah okay you
know what I'm now really hoping for is
that Jonathan guesses something wrong
I'm here by the way I'm hearing the
scene in the movie where she says
paprikash of idiot and finally in
Spider-Man no way home which of these
Peter Parker's is nicknamed Peter three
Andrew Garfield Peter Parker Tom
Hollands Peter Parker Toby Maguire is
Peter Parker I mean obviously the third
one I think you go out you think go Tom
Hanks
because Tom's gonna really make that
into a joke P3 what do you mean yeah
yeah or is Toby Peter number three no
he'd be number one outside down kiss but
you remember but in Spider-Man no way
home yeah I feel like the big dog
Spidermans would tell a little dog
yeah yeah do we know does anyone
actually know all right I mean yeah
I had such Authority and we
sorry guys I totally popular
[Music]
guy very clearly asked does anybody know
and you did not speak up Jonathan I feel
we really let you down here actually I
think I think I did great are we still
invited did the company Retreats we're
never gonna hang out again after this
um
my birthday yeah she got to lose on her
first thing you win some you lose some
you know but we all learned a little
something where Andrew Garfield yes
Peter number three that's what's
important yeah yeah thank you BuzzFeed
thank you this is really fun we hope you
enjoyed our BuzzFeed quiz that we
totally destroyed and killed and we hope
you love the movie check it out in
theaters and just one more thing happy
oh my God
oh my God happy birthday to you very
nice of you happy birthday dear
Catherine thank you thank you happy
birthday to you
oh thank you Jonathan we've got you a
new phone we got your couple oh thank
you okay oh thank you so much bye
BuzzFeed